você já ouviu falar de engajamento e
educação eu acho que é quase falar de
palavras que são sinônimos porque eu
acredito cada vez mais que a educação é
uma ferramenta fundamental pra gente
transformar o mundo e acho que esse dia
a gente está tendo aqui uma grande aula
pra todos né
de uma maneira bastante distinta eu sou
uma professora da rede municipal de
educação de belo horizonte sou mineira
nasci no interior de minas gerais e de
uma família negra cuja mãe é professora
e meu pai era um pouco de tudo ele foi
combatente é escritor escreveu que o
caderno do estado de minas letras e
artes e era ativista de uma agremiação
do movimento negro aqui de belo
horizonte chamada josé do patrocínio
isso na década de 60 que não é uma coisa
muito comum é para famílias negras
eu gosto sempre de começar falando de
educação contando um pouco essa história
porque eu falo que por uma brincadeira
do destino eu sou de uma família cujo
pai ea mãe dele puderam estudar
não sei não sem dificuldades porque
minha mãe no interior de minas mesmo
podendo pagar seus estudos ela foi
recusada em várias escolas particulares
do estado de minas gerais como ainda
hoje a gente vê acontecer em algumas
escolas do nosso país
não porque as pessoas recusam vaga até
porque o racismo que existe na nossa
sociedade cria uma série de estratégias
que muitas vezes nós negros
eu falo ciganos indígenas pobres no
brasil a gente tem que dar um jeitinho e
saindo né porque as pessoas vamos expor
o empurrando pra fora dos espaços e das
políticas públicas
queria contar um pouco
o de experiências vividas na agenda da
educação e falar do lugar onde eu tô
atualmente que a secretaria de educação
continuada alfabetização diversidade e
inclusão do ministério da educação uma
secretaria que basicamente trabalha com
alguns setores da população brasileira
que no processo de democratização da
educação ainda apresenta indicadores
educacionais desfavoráveis
então a secad é uma secretaria jovem no
âmbito da política educacional
brasileira ela tem 10 anos e ela se
estruturou para estabelecer políticas
para a população do campo e o campo
brasileiro vai da amazônia que a gente
já viu outro um pouco hoje dialogando
com o equador
mas né passa pelos pampas pelo centro
oeste mato grosso que planta soja
a população de pescadores ribeirinhos
quilombolas extrativistas uma
diversidade de situações no nosso país
que nos pede uma agenda de educação
diferenciada é também da secad nós
trabalhamos com políticas para juventude
eu queria depois tem uma fala importante
do que diz respeito à a juventude que eu
acho que é um tema importante hoje na
agenda educacional políticas para a
educação de jovens e adultos para aquela
população que pela pelas políticas
anteriormente desenvolvidas no nosso
país não tiveram acesso à educação na
idade né
mais jovem quando criança quando os
jovens é políticas para inclusão de
estudantes com deficiência transtornos
globais do desenvolvimento e altas
habilidades
então é uma agenda extensa sem falar da
discussão dos direitos de crianças e
adolescentes da necessidade de se pensar
políticas para a educação daquelas
pessoas que estão no sistema prisional
bem como para os adolescentes que estão
no sistema socioeducativo
queria contar experiências bem sucedidas
e algumas que nos chamam a refletir
sobre a necessidade de cada vez mais nos
engajarmos numa agenda da
educação mas não de qualquer educação
uma educação que se pense para a
diversidade dos sujeitos que nós temos
no nosso país uma primeira questão que
eu queria destacar é um projeto que nós
desenvolvemos em belo horizonte quer um
projeto da rede do 3º ciclo projeto bem
interessante que pensava na questão da
alfabetização de adolescentes na faixa
etária de 12 a 13 anos e que ainda não
sabiam ler e escrever
essa é uma grande luta do nosso país não
só trazemos todos as pessoas crianças e
adolescentes para a escola mas garantir
que ele seja alfabetizado em garantir
que eles aprendam e o projeto da rede do
3º ciclo ante essa característica a
gente queria que os que aqueles
adolescentes que estavam na escola mas
não estavam se alfabetizando se
alfabetização
esse projeto foi interessante porque foi
um projeto que se propôs a uma abertura
primeiro não trabalhar só com
professores a trabalhar com agentes
culturais trabalhar com outras pessoas é
que pode que poderiam atuar junto com
professores no desenvolvimento integral
desses estudantes
mas o que eu quero contar não é bem a
experiência do projeto o que aconteceu
com alguns adolescentes que moravam ali
na região do morro das pedras e que
estavam se deslocando financiados pela
prefeitura de belo horizonte de táxi até
o prédio da fafich que é um prédio que
fica lá no santo andré antigo já fiz um
prédio histórico que tem aqui em belo
horizonte
esses adolescentes saíram de táxi na
porta da escola e um pra esse prédio da
faf foram falados no meio do caminho
pela polícia ranqueados do táxi jogado
no chão colocado a arma na cabeça desses
estudantes o taxista falava mas não está
acontecendo nada esses adolescentes eu
faço isso toda semana é um trabalho que
a gente faz junto eles não são bandidos
mas foi difícil né foi preciso que ele
entrasse em contato com a secretaria de
educação para que a gente pudesse
esclarecer esse fato eu queria chamar
muita atenção disso nós estamos num
momento que essa
cidade brasileira avançou bastante do
ponto de vista da garantia dos direitos
hoje nós temos menores taxas de
mortalidade infantil
nós ampliamos a renda da de grande parte
das famílias brasileiras nós avançamos
nas taxas de escolarização
mas eu queria é dialogar muito com
também uma palestrante desse dia a a
palestrante da áfrica do sul que falou
que a garantia dos direitos né
a gente não pode relaxar
então o que eu estou dizendo nós estamos
nesse momento lá em brasília discutindo
o plano nacional de educação
e como é difícil a gente a cada dia
garantir com que direitos com que a
gente já há consenso na sociedade
brasileira que é da não discriminação do
respeito às pessoas da garantia da
educação a qualquer pessoa um sistema
educacional inclusivo independente da
cor da pele da sua condição física da
sua condição sensorial independente do
seu local de origem que todas as pessoas
têm direito à educação e que não podem
ser discriminadas por isso que a gente
precisa fazer uma educação que dialogue
com diferentes espaços uma educação que
seja integral que ps do ponto de vista
da sustentabilidade e que não fique só
dentro da escola mas que possa dialogar
com vários espaços no entorno da escola
é isso não é uma garantia que aposta
isso não existisse cotidianamente nós
não construímos essa agenda nas
diferentes coisas que a gente faz e
assistindo que tudo ao longo desse dia
fiquei pensando como que a gente precisa
é o tempo todo tá no no engajamento da
militância e aí não importa muito qual
que é o tema né
importa eu acho que cada vez mais é a
gente pensar na perspectiva dos direitos
humanos
e aí dos direitos humanos e tudo é o que
nos remete a um engajamento dessa
natureza é
pensar na diversidade da sociedade
brasileira e pensar isso do ponto de
vista educacional é fazer um esforço
muito grande de transformação do próprio
estado porque o nosso estado ele não foi
instituído para dar conta das diferentes
diferenças
então por que a gente pensa que tem uma
secretaria que cuida dessa temática toda
a diversidade dispensa bom mas isso não
está em todos os lugares
nós queremos que esteja em todos os
lugares mas de fato isso ainda não é
fato na nossa sociedade e nós precisamos
avançar cada vez mais com essa agenda eu
queria ainda falar de uma experiência
importante e vida que minas gerais que a
experiência da educação escolar indígena
onde eu fui trabalhar com a educação
indígena
lá em 1994 e convidado para trabalhar na
educação indígena eu falei prometem de
minas e olha que eu me considerava uma
pessoa bem bacanas e me considero uma
pessoa antenada com o que está
acontecendo é eu falei pô mas sim 90 tem
indenizem a criança mesmo que tá né
na minha região sul ac do centro oeste
não sabia aí fiquei conhecendo né que é
um movimento maravilhoso a gente tinha
que naquele momento povo xacriabá krenak
maxacali pataxó lutando pela instituição
de educação escolar indígena e eu me
deparei 1994 com uma agenda muito forte
no nosso estado porque nós tínhamos um
município inteiro por exemplo o
município de são joão das missões que
mais de 70% da população é população
indígena xacriabá e que tinha um y
elevado de analfabetismo
naquele momento naquele município a
gente tinha trabalhando né com as
populações indígenas do município 15
professores que as palavras eram
professores brancos né e professores que
iam nas escolas indígenas é não com
muita freqüência é conhecido aquele
momento comunidades inteiras que não
tinha nenhuma criança alfabetizada
nenhum adolescente alfabetizado não tem
muito tempo mas hoje quando a gente olha
o brasil nós ainda temos municípios
brasileiros que têm mais de 40% da
população analfabeta e muitas vezes do
lugar onde a gente está no município
onde a gente está que a gente está mais
aqui no sudeste
a gente não se dá conta dessa dimensão
do grande esforço que nós ainda temos
que fazer na sociedade brasileira
pra quê de fato a gente transforma
transforme construa uma sociedade mais
igualitária do ponto de vista do acesso
educacional
então a gente começou faluja
analfabetismo mas a gente tem que falar
do acesso à educação superior
você tem que falar de educação básica de
falar do acesso à educação superior
porque também na educação superior
nós temos ainda situação de bastante
desigualdade e 2012 nós conseguimos
aprovar a lei que estabelece cotas para
estudantes de escola pública e cotas
raciais nas universidades federais do
brasil
de acordo com o contingente populacional
que é medido pelo ibge
bom isso foi um grande avanço e aí só
pra dizer num movimento negro já havia
lutado por cotas há muitos anos e muitas
universidades por iniciativas próprias
há pelo menos dez anos desde 2002 já vem
implementando mecanismo de cotas é
eternas as instituições por definições
próprias e nós avançamos pra caramba
nesses indicadores só você saber né lá
em 2003 2004 a gente tinha é 0,5 por
cento de negros nas universidades
federais brasileiras avançam da nossa em
4% né
então agora vamos avançar mais que com a
lei de cotas de a partir desde o ano
passado nós vamos avançando é nessa
agenda até chegar o contingente
populacional
então é essa agenda é que eu falo um
pouco de tudo ela não é simples ela
precisa ser construída cotidianamente e
pra pensar para o futuro o que eu acho
que é fundamental na nossa pauta atual
né
o debate da educação integral pensão
o projeto de educação integral para o
brasil que pense desde a infância desde
as crianças né
é de qualquer lugar do nosso país a
juventude é uma questão fundamental nós
somos um dos países é do mundo e da
américa latina que tem a menor jornada
escolar
então nós precisamos ampliar o tempo dos
estudantes em atividades educativas
agora pensar na ampliação do tempo não é
só pensar numa escola de tempo integral
gente como eu costumo brincar muito em
minas gerais quando a gente chega na
cidade do interior normalmente às vezes
não tem nada apurado na cidade mas tem
duas coisas que com certeza é morar numa
cidade cemitério ea escola sem sombra de
dúvida ele precisa mudar essa situação
pensar um projeto de educação integral é
pensar um projeto de município educador
a gente costuma falar o município
educador sustentável saudável ea gente
vai por muitos adjetivos mas é porque
pensam um projecto educativo é pensar um
projeto sociedade é pensar um projeto de
país é pensar que cidade que a gente
quer viver que município nós queremos
viver
como é que nós vamos cuidar daquelas
pessoas que trabalham com a agricultura
familiar
que tipo de educação espera é nossos
pescadores das comunidades extrativistas
das comunidades nas florestas
hoje a gente briga com o pessoal do
campo que eles farão não é só educação
do campo é escola das florestas a escola
das águas
nós precisamos pensar nessa diversidade
uma escola para o cerrado para o
semiárido brasileiro que tem bastante
diferenciação mas tem uma coisa que é
fundamental independente do lugar onde a
gente for fazer escola e independente do
sujeito com os quais a gente está
trabalhando a gente precisa pensar mais
no ser humano
mais do que nunca pensar no ser humano e
mais do que nunca eu queria chamar gente
a pensar na juventude brasileira um país
onde 50 mil pessoas são assassinadas por
ano e 40 com cento dessas tem menos de
24 anos e em sua maioria são
jovens negros pobres favelados da
periferia não pode se manter em silêncio
e não pode ter um projeto aguerrido de
educação pra combater esse tipo de
situação o combate ao racismo o combate
às desigualdades de qualquer natureza
não é possível a gente fazer se a gente
não tiver um grande projeto educacional
do país
é isso que eu defendi acho que a gente
tem que fazer isso no dia a dia com
muitas práticas a muitas mãos com muitas
idéias com muita gente dando pitaco de
todas as áreas o que não é uma coisa
fácil porque o professor assim como
várias outras categorias profissionais
nós somos muito ciosos do nosso lugar do
saber e do conhecimento
mas a perspectiva de uma educação
dialógica e da necessidade de dialogar
eu acho que ela é fundamental se nós
quisermos avançar nessa agenda e tem uma
frase com o qual eu queria concluir é só
pra dizer de mais uma área de desafio da
secad que é a questão da educação da
população cigana eu queria concluir a
minha fala com uma fala dos ciganos que
esses né na sociedade brasileira eles
são invisíveis não só porque a gente vai
visibilizar mas mesmo a discussão das
estatísticas que nós avançamos muito
quando a gente pensa a população
indígena quando a gente pensa população
negra
nós não encontramos estatística sobre a
população cigana no brasil e eles hoje
defendem fortemente uma agenda do estado
para a o avanço educacional porque a
população cigana é assistir a estimativa
é que 47 por cento da população cigana
brasileira é analfabeta então acho que
essa meta é muito importante e pra nós
que estamos nessa perspectiva de
engajamento o engajamento ele não é
individual
anda quando natália me apresentou falou
natália eu sou feliz porque meu
engajamento é onde eu tô é onde eu
trabalho feliz pra mim mas eu acho que a
felicidade para todos nós e os ciganos
nos ensinos se o caminho é longo a gente
não pode andar sozinho eu acho que isso
aqui é um movimento pra gente andar
junto pra transformação do nosso país